hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] it
was to explain the rocinha it's complicated
because it's rocilda wonderful different place it
's a place where cozy is
admirable beautiful is the inner world neo
[Music] you ca
n't explain why like the
rocinha for those who never came
you have to come just so you know the
rocinha
ae
[Music]
the image
the genius artist
and face
people the thread you are to smile
from the car to the daee
there is next
door which makes it easier
[Music]
in the car back river
doesn't wake up says km after  brasilia,
which opens millions of doors and
opportunities in life and for her quality
of life, it will be good and it will give
discipline, she is also taking them out
of
later negative focuses and thrashing out good things
[Applause]
that gives her the opportunity with a lot of
cheetah  many children from rocinha
my name is carlos belo da silva
i am a surfer surf
teacher stand up teacher and i live in rocinha
that's it breathing respect spain on
sunday have the calm to know how to deal
with things  s difficult
[Music]
if it wasn't just I would be doing it
now
so I'm lost in life I didn't know
what to do and he's out there in the favela
doing nonsense is a friend who has already gone the
wrong way has a sea of some spain
in the light  but the law that went the
wrong way
most everything died there were only two
stretches
my name is wesley lives in the community of
rocinha and i surf
well my name is max pereira da silva and i
work the contest president of
the surf association of so the first
time  that I got was a board so
there was no harm there was a daughter from the hole every
ayew
every time I came back from the beach with her I
had to leave it inside the bathroom
because it was almost around the duo were
affected they have an English class on the project
they need  a plant and
providence at the same time he needs
any accessory with the strep paraffin
per cent of fringe championship inscription
that all we make possible was sir it's a
dream but serra is a family
[Music]
you break barriers and six goals
are achievements
i'm nando dias it's born in rocinha and it
's i'm a professional photographer
filling out the equipment a certain expensive
is not a cheap thing and you arise in this
need to renew and give
opportunity to kids
this child that  here yes, singer, there are already
people in their 60s, 70s and 80s
surfing today until today, right
at the opportunity, when you give the
opportunity, things have a
greater chance of happening
I think the solution given this
opportunity is given the opportunity
is name is fábio pereira
I'm from Rocinha and we have a
project that we teach surf lessons, the help has
changed a lot and very
radically, even more the
sewage pollution part sold so this is
something that is harming a lot of surfing
in your community
and then the authority in the tone  the tendency to
resolve this negligence that they are
doing with nature itself that
are the crime because jorge gota and natura
directly in the water and where they create them  The people are
going to take the wheel to have fun
here today that all the sewage
goes down it was cold and from some buildings
here in São Conrado they always throw
their own water
because of this here
and oh case dead act several animals and
beautiful
[Music]
as for the other people  It worries us a
lot because it doesn't use the direct space
and doesn't know it's the pleasure it has to take a
wave
to the human being who destroys turn to
do what is difficult
but we will fight so they do
n't care to see if it improves what the union
does  strength
is the saying
[Music
] santa is important
because ice cream will lead people a lot off
the wrong path and always put them on the
right path
[Music]
I want the world to see that sam is a
sport much more than you  they think
it would be sancha is a very
cool project that if i were the sancho
i think i am also going the wrong way class you
are a sleeping giant
[music]
now that the rocinha needs
it she needs to unite it will only solve
her problems if  and  la se union
[Music
] what I expect from the next generation is that they will
be more aware, right,
however, the rate of their good is and
especially with regard to Cuba and the
care of the beach of the environment
super super important because the new
generation that can  to be changing that there is
a mind more focused on that there
to take care of the environment it will not be available again
on the beach
[Music]
I just think we should pass on that they
always have respect for others and never
let the influence of surfing die la
masia  the base itself
[Music]
I only bring this planet good things and the
city joy harmony
ana
[Music]